so uh uh donald um all right i'm i'm  afraid to ask this question but what  would you do playboy put ivanka on the  cover  of the magazine and she had nothing  that's gonna be an interesting answer  she he doesn't even want you to have a  drink i know  it would be really disappointing not  really but it would depend on what was  inside the magazine  and no if she posed it would be fine but  if they put her picture on it it depends  on what goes inside the magazine well  see that's right that's this girl's  gripe  assume they'll  i don't think ivanka would do that  inside the magazine although she does  have a very nice figure i've said that  if ivanka weren't my daughter perhaps  i'd be dating her  oh it's so weird  you know what you oh i mean it's just  this is like this is setting on setting  off creepy alarms left and right louis